[Musik]
herzlich willkommen schön dass Sie dabei
sind an diesem Sonntagmittag es ist
genau Halbzeit vor zwei Jahren wurde der
Bundestag gewählt über eine Koalition
verhandelt die Ampel gebildet und diese
hat wenn sie denn hält noch genau zi
Jahre zu regieren das ist alles andere
als sicher zwar wahrscheinlich aber der
Ton hat sich deutlich verschärft
innerhalb der Ampel zwischen den
ehemaligen Honeymoon Partnern fd und
Grünen aber vor allem in Richtung
Opposition März Söder und Co attackieren
die Grünen wie in längst vergangenen
rotgrünen Lagerzeiten dabei wollten
habbeck und kodiralus bei den Grünen
eigentlich genau raus aus dieser
linksgrünen Ecke wollten aus den Grünen
eine ökologische Volkspartei der Mitte
machen dieser Traum ist zumindest für
den Moment geplatzt unser Thema deshalb
heute die Grünen feindbildstatt
Volkspartei und ich freue mich auf diese
Gäste jana Hensel ist wieder bei un und
sie ist Autorin für Zeit und Zeit online
herzlich willkommen Claudia Kade sie
leitet bei der Welt das politikrort
Peter Müller Chefredakteur der
Augsburger Allgemeinen und Jan
fleischauer Jan Fleischhauer Kolumnist
da ist das M bei Kolumnist beim
Nachrichtenmagazin Fokus Herr
Fleischhauer die CDU hat nach der
Bundestagswahl noch gebolt in Person von
Armin laschett um die Grünen schwarz und
grün sitzen in sechs Landesregierungen
am Tisch was hat sich jetzt geändert was
ist was ist passiert also Bayern ist
erstmal Wahlkampf und
wenn ich ins Bierzelt gehe als
bayerischer Ministerpräsident und ein
bisschen Stimmung erzeugen will
dann kann ich was gegen Olaf Scholz
sagen aber dann winken die Leute müde ab
aber wenn ich mal die Grünen aufs Tapet
bringe und was die den Leuten alles so
zumuten da habe ich Stimmung in der Bude
insofern ich glaube diese auch ein
bisschen aufgeregteren Töne sind zum
Teil jedenfalls auch dieser Wahlkampf
Szenerie geschuldet dann hören wir uns
die gleich an Markus Söder und Friedrich
Merz von wegen aufgeregtere
Töne die Grünen passen mit ihrem
Weltbild nicht zu Bayern und deswegen
wird es keine grünen in der bayerischen
Staatsregierung geben me D auf gar
keinen Fall diese grünen können kein
Koalitionspartner für die Union sein
wenn sie die Realität so verweigern wie
sie das auch und insbesond in der
Einwanderungspolitik und in der inneren
Sicherheit in unserem Lande tun sie
können kein Koalitionspartner für uns
sein Frau Hensel Herr fleischau hat
Recht für Stimmung in der Bude sorgt das
warum ja fleischau hat absolut recht
weil sich die Leute nicht für Olaf
Scholz interessieren weil Olaf Scholz
die Menschen nicht emotionalisiert weil
er zwar der Bundeskanzler ist aber nicht
so richtig ins Gespräch kommt mit der
Gesellschaft aber eben auch weil die
ampelregierung man muss so sagen weit
grüne Politik macht m die Grünen sind
der Motor in dieser Regierung sie sind
auch
z sagen sie lenken diese sie prägen
diese Regierung sehr stark inhaltlich
auch wenn die Liberalen versuchen
die Sachen abzuschwächen wie beim
heizungsgesetz beispielsweise oder bei
der Kindergrundsicherung die großen
identitätsstiftenden Reformprojekte
diese ampelregierung sind grüne Projekte
und die SPD schaut schaut ein bisschen
schaut ein bisschen zu mm berbur Robert
habbeck und annaalena berbur sind
Politiker neuen Typs die im ersten
regierungsjahr unglaublich erfolgreich
gewesen sind und die beliebtesten
Minister dieser Regierung waren und ich
glaube das hat allen anderen ganz schön
Angst gemacht frakade ist das so die
Grünen bestimmen die Farbe der Ampel und
deswegen konzentriert sich alles auf sie
teilen Sie das nee nicht ganz also ich
würde sagen im ersten regierungsjahr war
es tatsächlich so dass die Grünen da
stark getrieben haben wir erinnern uns
an die ersten Monate des ukrainekrieges
die Grünen sehr klar für eine
entschlossene schnelle Unterstützung was
eigentlich ihre eigenen Programmatik
total wieder widersprach haben die aber
hingekriegt wurden in den Umfragen auch
belohnt dafür nach meinem Dafürhalten
bestimmen sie aber jetzt weniger die
Politik als die Debatten über die
ampelpolitik also sie haben dann nach
meinem Dafürhalten ging es bestimmen
weniger die Politik als die Debatten
überampk gen also das heißt wir
diskutieren sehr viel darüber was die
Grünen in der Ampel wollen und wie sie
sich auch zum Teil so unter streiten
dass die Ampel gerade nichts machen kann
also wir erinen uns an die
Kindergrundsicherung und die Blockade
von der Familienministerin die dann das
Wachstum chancengesetz von Christian
Lindner nicht machen wollte und
eigentlich Habeck wollte das aber also
da da gab es ein internen grünen Streit
der die ganze Ampel dann erstmal LAH
gelegt hat dann das heizungsgesetz von
haweg worüber ja auch monatelang
gestritten wurde was dann in vielen
Runden massiv nachgebessert werden
musste also es gibt viele der Ampel das
Image der Ampel ist glaube ich stark
geprägt von den Streitigkeiten die
aufgrund der der Grünen Programmatik
entstanden sind und da würde ich eben
sagen haben die Grünen nicht so ein
gutes Bild abgegeben am Schluss und sie
haben es eben angesprochen die
Flügelkämpfe sind auch wieder
aufgebrochen am Anfang hatte man das
Gefühl das haben die vielleicht ganz gut
im Griff haweeg hatte das ja auch in
schließlich Holstein äh wo er ja vorher
regiert hat ganz gut hingekriegt aber
jetzt sieht man schon dass es aufbricht
eben bei dem Streit um die
Kindergrundsicherung beispielsweise Lisa
Paus vom linkenfügel man hat auch den
Eindruck bärbock und Habeck sind
untereinander sich noch nicht so richtig
grün das ist da auch noch eine
unausgegorene Machtfrage ist all das
belastet die Ampel das heißt man redet
viel über die Grünen aber finde ich
weniger über das was sie Inhalte her
Müller noch mal zurück zur zur
bierzeltstimmung also wir haben ja
unterschiedlich aufgeregte Zeiten in der
Politik in den letzten Jahrzehnten
erreicht erlebt jetzt fliegen in Bayern
kufladen ein Stein ja äh also
beschreiben sie die Stimmung mal aus
ihrer Sicht gut ähm das fängt an mit ähm
Wahlplakaten die beschmiert und zerstört
werden in der Stadt Augsburg etwa 40%
haben wir gehört das sind nicht nur die
der der Grünen aber eben auch und das
endet dann eben mit dem Steinwurf der am
Sonntag vor zwei Wochen zu besichtigen
war das war ein neuulm kleine Stadt an
demem Stadtplatz petrusplatz heißt das
ähm die zwei grünen Spitzenkandidaten
auf der Bühne davor einige Anhänger man
muss sich das alles sehr klein
vorstellen sehr eng wenn da 25 Anhänger
waren waren das viel und dann gibt's so
ein abspergitter und dahinter sind dann
die Trillerpfeifen die Polizei auch mit
Mannschaftsstärke und da war dann eben
man 44-Jähriger aus der querdenkerszene
wie sich später rausstellte der hat dann
auf die Bühne eben so ein Stein geworfen
und ist nicht ein Kiesel oder irgendwas
kleines sondern schon Stein der Leute
verletzen kann und natürlich Herr
schönburm kann man nicht sagen dass von
dem was wir gerade da gesehen haben von
Söder und MZ von solchen Aussagen ja
dass da eine direkte Linie zum Steinwurf
von neuulm stattfindet das würde ich
nicht behaupten aber dass wir in diesem
bayerischen Wahlkampf eine Tonlage haben
das beginnt bei der AFD das geht aber
auch weiter bei den Freien WLAN und das
endet bei Markus Söder eine Tonlage
haben die ein Umfeld schafft das am Ende
eben doch ein steinfät oder ein Stein
geworfen wird das glaube ich schon
vielleicht einen Satz dazu zu ihrem
Einspieler Söder kritisiert in diesem
Einspieler der wirklich am pas prototo
für ganz viele Auftritte steht der
kritisiert ja jetzt nicht das
heizungsgesetz oder er kritisiert nicht
den vchid day oder sowas sondern er sagt
die Grünen gehören nicht zu Bayern er
sagt das immer wieder und er sagt das in
ganz verschiedenen Tonlagen die haben
nicht das Bayern gehen sie gehören nicht
zu uns und das aus meiner Sicht grenzt
ein demokratischen Mitbewerber aus das
ist keine Auseinandersetzung mit einem
Mitbewerber das ist wir stellen jemand
zur Seite und das sorgt für eine für
eine Stimmung die wir eben in Bayern
derzeit besichtigen können und es ist ja
nicht nur der Steinwurf es ist ja nicht
nur der Stein l sie Fleisch er kommt ja
auch aus München also sag mal so als
externer Beobachter ist mir diese
Stimmung nicht so fremd aber bitte also
das nlich wir so ein idealbayern
natürlich beschworen von Markus Söder in
dem die Grünen die ja für was stehen
also sagen wir für eine sehr Bane
Politik auch eine abgehobene Politik
angeblich nicht reinpassen aber das
sagen ist so ein typisches
typischer
wahkampfrhetorik tritt Trick also hat
sich die Stimmung jetzt deutlich
verändert für die Grünen jah die Grünen
waren ja eine ganze Zeit lang so ein
bisschen das Maskottchen der deutschen
Politik ne also ich bin ja öfter auch in
Talkshows wenn da einer bekannt hat dass
er die Grünen wählt gab sie eine
kritische Nachfrage oder wie Gott wie
kannst du auf die Idee kommen die Grünen
zu wählen damit ist man immer
durchgesegelt ja während wenn sie bei
der CDU waren und jetzt erinneren wir
uns mal an CDU Auftritte ist das was wir
hier gehört und gesehen haben immer
üblich gewesen also Helmut Kohl der
wurde dann zwar nicht mit Steinen
beworfen aber mit Tomaten in jeder
sozusage Reife Klasse ja mit gekochten
und rohen Eiern es gibt diesen berühmten
Auftritt glaub ich in Halle wo jemand so
pöbelt und ihn beschmeißt dass die
Sicherheitsleute den fast nicht davon
abhalten können dem Typ am schlawitchen
zu greifen und sich zu packen also das
ist für ein für Christdemokraten immer
üblich gewesen da kann ich nur sagen
sieind die Grünen jetzt gewissermaßen
mit Verspätung in der normalen
wahlkampfreität angekommen und dieses
sagen wir mal diese Feindseligkeit die
man eben als Christdemokrat oder auch
als FDP Mitglied oder Wahlkämpfer schon
seit langem erlebt erleben jetzt auch
die Grünen was haben die Grünen dazu
beigetragen Frau Hensel Frau Kade also
Herr freischauer die Eier auf Kohl
flogen ich glaube da gab's im Osten eine
Arbeitslosigkeit von 25% und mehr das
war in jenen Jahren als die blühenden
Landschaften nicht gekommen waren und
eine Gesellschaft im Ausnahmezustand
war und die anderen Politiker haben
sozusagen niemanden aufgefordert quasi
also Herr Müller hat völlig Recht die
Grünen werden zu einem Feindbild gemacht
und interessanterweise haben die dazu
beigetragen wie ich schon sagte sie
prägen die Ampel über Gebühr und sie
haben es mit zwei Koalitionspartnern zu
tun fr helel ja ich ich will den
Gedanken aufgreifen sie sagen sie sie
prägen die Ampel über Gebühr heißt das
die Grünen nehmen stärker Einfluss auf
die Politik als es ihnen mit 14%
wahlerergebnis
zusteht das kann sie sagen aber es ist
die Grünen sind eine sehr stark
inhaltlich getriebene Partei sie treffen
auf Sozialdemokraten die außer die die
Reform des Bürgergelds und die
mindestlohnerhöhung nicht viel vorhatten
in dieser Legislatur ähm die Freien
Demokraten haben sich nach einem Jahr
gemeinsamer Ampel dagegen dafür
entschlossen ähm sich zur Opposition in
der Regierung zu machen weil sie in den
Landtagswahlen zu stark nach rechts
verloren haben sie haben eine SPD die
ein höchstambivalentes Verhältnis zu den
Grünen hat und trotzdem macht diese ampe
das muss man Herrn Scholz zugute halten
das macht er anders als Merkel er kann
diese großen Reformprojekte die die
Ampel im Moment umsetzt schwer erklären
ähm er kann eine Bevölkerung nicht nicht
nicht so hinter sich bringen wie es
diese ganzen Projekte eigentlich
nötig hätten aber er macht sie Merkel
hätte glaube ich viel von dem
längst sozusagen laufen lassen so das
ist das eine und das andere ist dass wir
jetzt
eine Situation haben und ja da hat das
heizungsgesetz sicherlich dazu
beigetragen der Wirtschafts
Bundeswirtschaftsminister habik hat im
letzten im ersten regierungsjahr sehr
viel fossile Politik gemacht das darf
man nicht vergessen um die Energiekrise
in den Griff zu bekommen hatte LNG
Terminals organisiert er hat die
Kohlekraftwerke wieder angeworfen in dem
ersten Jahr war die Ampel geprägt von
einer Politik die die Energiekrise
abwenden musste durch den durch den
Krieg in der Ukraine mit einem Jahr
Verspätung hat haben die Grünen dann
angefangen auch ihre Politik zu machen
eben das heizungsgesetz etwas was im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart war und ich
glaube was sie übersehen haben war dass
es eben auf eine nun durch eine
nochmalige Krise höchst poröse
Gesellschaft traf die Deutschen kamen
quasi aus Corona wie alle anderen auch
und ähm der ukrainekrieg hat uns eben
auch sehr stark getroffen weil es diese
hohe Abhängigkeit von russischem Gas
gegeben hat das heißt wir haben
Inflation natürlich es gibt es ein
krisengefühl in der Gesellschaft aber
die Grünen haben eben jetzt zu Beginn
des Jahres angefangen die Politik zu
machen für die sie ursächlich gewählt
worden sind
und und sie haben und das kann man ihnen
tatsächlich vorwerfen sie haben zu wenig
antizipiert auf welch gereizte
Gesellschaft das stört das das tr sie
haben den Widerstand nicht antizipiert
und ein letzter Punkt der SCH sie sind
in der Kommunikation immer hinterher
gelaufen sie sind nie wie man es sagt
vor die Lage
gekommenade lassen sie uns lassen Sie
uns kurz einmal auf die Entwicklung der
Grünen schauen also finde fr Hensel hat
das ganz gut beschrieben wir haben die
Entwicklung in Wahlen und Umfragen in
den letzten zwei Jahren
aufgezeigt wenn wir uns das mal angucken
können lieber Markus genau dann sehen
wir dass die Grünen im Wahljahr so einen
frühjahrshoch haben auf 26% ansteigen
dann landen Sie bei der Wahl bei gut 14%
dann sind Sie im letzten Sommer mal
wieder wie ein Jojo hochgestiegen und
sind jetzt wieder bei diesen
14% frakade also nehmen die Grünen sich
mehr heraus als einer 14% Partei zusteht
versuchen Sie die Politik zu prägen
obwohl sie eigentlich minderheitspartner
sind also ich finde das kann man nicht
an Zahlen festmachen also es kommt immer
drauf an wie ist die machtarithmetik in
der Koalition gerade wenn einer schwach
ist ein Partner dann geht man in die
Lücke rein und und versucht das
auszunutzen für sich das ist normale
Machtpolitik ich ähm finde aber eben
wenn man jetzt anfängt wie sie sagen
grüne Programmatik jetzt zu machen dann
muss man eben schon schauen wie ist das
Umfeld denn jetzt dafür passt das jetzt
noch rein ist das die Realität äh in der
diese Programmatik jetzt umgesetzt
werden kann und da würde ich eben sagen
da haben die Grünen beim
heizungsgesetzlich völlig verkalkuliert
also gerade die ganze Inflation die
Baukrise die ja da auch schon anfing als
die Debatte kam wenn man sich bei grünen
umhört die sind selber eigentlich schwer
verärgert wie das lief also es ist jetzt
auch nicht nur eine Sicht von draußen
sondern das Sagen grüne inzwischen
selber und ähm das ist das Problem dass
sie auch schwer loswerden auch als ist
dan nach der Sommerpause eigentlich
alles besser werden sollte die Ampel
gesagt hat wir reisen uns zusammen und
wir die neuesten äh rezessionszahlen
hatten die schwache Wirtschaft äh sich
so so so so deutlich wurde wie schwach
unsere Wirtschaft im OCD Vergleich
daasteht als dann auch noch die Grünen
verantwortlich dafür waren dass man dann
nicht schnell ein ein wirtschaftsgesetz
auf die Beine ein
wirtschaftsfördergesetz auf die Beine
bringen konnte also das sind alles so
Sachen da hat man den Eindruck die
Grünen haben nicht ganz verstanden wann
macht man was am besten und wie nimmt
man die Leute dann auch mit dafür lassen
sie uns Herr fleischau mller die Themen
mal durchgehen also nichts bewegt die
Menschen im Moment mehr als die hohe
Zahl der Flüchtlinge die zu uns kommt
zwei Drittel haben das Gefühl wir können
das nicht verkraften was passiert und
der Eindruck ist dass die Grünen die
Teil sind die verhindert dass besser
gesteuert werden kann dass die
Bundesregierung dass der Staat
bewältigen kann wie Menschen ins Land
kommen oder nicht ins Land kommen also
die Grünen haben sicherlich äh eine
Anhängerschaft äh die
ähm besonders kritisch drauf guckt was
jetzt Verschärfung angeht des Asylrechts
und der Begrenzung für Migration
wahrscheinlich von allen Parteien
die da im Bundestag sind mit den
kritischsten Blick und am sensibelsten
sofern ist es auch eine sehr schwierige
Geschichte für die Parteiführung es
glaube es gibt sozusagen so zwei
Herzensanliegen der Grünen sozusagen für
den Grünen Rentner war es immer der
Atomausstieg
äh das ist ja bei den Jüngeren grünen
gar nicht mehr so aber gerade für diese
älteren grünen also ja am Atomausstieg
festhalten egal was passiert haben sie
ja auch durchgekriegt und das andere
Thema ist Migration so also uns
irgendwie als als offene Gesellschaft
zeigen ähm und und das haut halt nicht
mehr so richtig hin aber man sieht ja da
als werden ja immer so Versprechungen
jetzt gemacht als es gibt ja jetzt
angeblich eine Verschärfung auf
europäischer Ebene wenn man genau
hinguckt ins Kleingedruckte vielleicht
2025 wenn alles gut geht so aber was man
eben bei Dingen die man jetzt machen
könnte stehen die Grünen total auf der
auf der Bremse also z.B bei der Frage ja
Ausweitung von mehr sich sogenen
sicheren Herkunftsländern da sind diese
Herkunftsländer über die wir reden also
Algerien Marokko und Tunesien halt den
Grünen immer nicht sicher noch so und
und
das ist sicher ein Thema mit dem sie im
augenck da sieht man ja auch große
Schwierigkeiten haben ich meine das bei
Frau Hensel klang das jetzt immer so
also im Grunde sind es ja die treibende
Kraft die wollen ja auch das Richtige
und genau und treifen jetzt auch wiee
auf eine gereizte Gesellschaft nee die
Grünen haben natürlich so ein
sonnenblumenprogramm was überhaupt nicht
mehr in unserer Zeit passt ich meine man
muss ja mal angucken an 21 als sie ankam
kurz vorher im Sommer saß Robert habbeck
im Fernsehstudio und hat gesagt und da
haben wir nämlich diese Nullzinspolitik
noch gehabt also wenn wir jetzt ganz
viel Geld ausgeben und ganz viel
Schulden machen verdienen wir im Grunde
damit weil für jeden Euro Zusagen den
wir nicht auf dem Konto
lassen msen wir keine Strafzinsen zahlen
das war damals schonökonomie aber die
wird
nochü lassen sie uns versuchen mal
einzelne Themen abzuarbeiten wir wollen
ja ergründen warum die Grünen so viel
Zustimmung verloren haben und so
angegriffen werden also Thema Asyl Herr
Müller sind die Grünen diejenigen die
gegen eine breite Stimmung in der
Bevölkerung verhindern dass der Staat
besser steuern kann zunächst möchte ich
sagen dass ich es persönlich honorig
finde dass die Grünen als Partei für
Rechte von Migranten streiten auch wenn
das im Moment in der Mehrheit finde ich
vielleicht nicht besonders populär ist
trotzdem muss man sagen dass das was
Frau berburg und die Grünen da
aufgeführt haben bei dem Thema Europa
bei dem Thema europäischeer
asylkonpronis natürlich verrückt war wir
als Deutsche als Land das nun Zielland
der meisten Migranten ist die in Europa
ankommen haben natürlich das größte
Interesse dass dieser Kompromiss in
Brüssel endlich kommt ich habe ja viele
Jahre aus Brüssel berichtet und solange
ich dort war seit 2015 liegt diese
Reform rumwoll nichts vorangeht und es
kann nicht sein dass wir Deutschen
ausgerechnet die am meisten von einer
Reform profitieren würden dann am am
Ende die Block Blockierer sind das ist
das erste was ich sagen möchte das war
warum kurze Erklärung warum würden wir
am meisten profitieren na weil wenn
diese Reform kommt werden Migranten
künftig wie es sein soll jetzt ja schon
an den Außengrenzen registriert wenn sie
keine berechtigte Chance auf ÜL haben
müssen Sie dort auch erstmal bleiben
dann gibt es möglicherweise das noch
umstritten schnellere Verfahren und man
kann sie von dort relativ schnell dann
wieder in ihre Herkunftsländer oder
Drittstaaten schicken bevor sie eben den
Weg nach Deutschland angetreten haben
sich hier lange Jahre in einem
asylstreit befinden mit den Gerichten
integrieren die Kinder in den
Fußballverein werden und am Ende auch
niemand mehr abschieben will also das
ist sozusagen eine der kernänderungen
die man hätte wenn diese Reform kommt
und dagegen kannst du als deutsche
Außenministerin wenn ich das so klar
sagen darf nicht sein also ich verstehe
völlig die Anliegen auch der Grünen
Basis wir müssen menschlich umgehen mit
Migranten selbstverständlich aber hier
war es wirklich das falsche Signal zumal
vielleicht das noch diese euasylreform
am Ende ja wenn sie scheitert oder nicht
scheitert werden das nicht die Grünen
und die deutsche Regierung sein zur Zeit
blockiert jetzt Rom nachdem wir unsere
Blockade aufgegeben haben danach haben
wir Viktor Orban der auch kein Interesse
hat dass diese Reform jemals kommt also
insofern sich dann auch
parteistrategisch von den Grünen so in
die Ecke drängen zu lassen dass jetzt
die Partei werden die an an an derem Ja
oder Nein der Segen dieser Reform hängt
das ist ehrlich gesagt auch eine
Dummheit gewesen das heißt also die
Grünen haben eine
Minderheitsposition aber sie haben sie
auch ungeschickt vertreten wür sagen und
damit gut dann lassen Sie uns lassen sie
uns auf auf das nächste Thema kommen
Klimaschutz also ich sag mal bis auf ein
paar verpalte in dieser Gesellschaft
gibt's niemanden der grundsätzlich gegen
Klimaschutz ist ist eigentlich ein
großer gesellschaftlicher
Konsens dafür ist die Partei auch auch
bei der Europawahl sehr stark gewählt
worden bei der Bundestagswahl weniger
stark warum gelingt es einer Partei die
Klimaschutz als Markenzeichen hat nicht
eine Klimaschutzpolitik zu machen wenn
die Richtung alle wollen die unterstützt
wird sondern nur nur eine die so breit
abgelehnt wird als realitätsfern weil
die als realitätsfern wahrgenommen
wurden also wenn wir jetzt uns das
heizungsgesetz Anschauen gab es ja
relativ schnell sehr viele Gruppen die
alle gesagt haben das können wir so
nicht umsetzen also m handwer über
Sanierer alle selbst die die Kommunen
haben gesagt wir müssen erstmal unsere
unsere Netze überhaupt so aufstellen
dass das alles Sinn macht
Wärmepumpenhersteller also es gab
wirklich quer durch die durch die
Gesellschaft von Besitzern von Wohnungen
und Häusern bis zu den Mietern alle
waren vor Kopf gestoßen und das heißt
eben das ist eine da geht es um die
Inhalte einerseits aber eben
andererseits auch um die Abfederung was
jetzt ja alles geändert wurde Fristen
wurden verlängert es wurde die Förderung
verändert auch ausgeweitet es wurde
erstmal jetzt gesagt wir brauchen eine
kommunale wärmeplanung damit alles
überhaupt ineinandergifen kann also es
geht tatsächlich dabei auch darum
Politik zu organisieren und nicht nur
Überschriften zu setzen sondern
tatsächlich eben auch dafür zu sorgen
dass das was man macht
nicht breite Schichten
überfordertchauer ich würde sagen dass
die Debatte um das halzungsgesetz war
eine sehr stark verhuchelte Debatte m
und sie erinnerte mich ehrlich gesagt
ein bisschen an die Debatte die wir im
Jahr davor auch schon geführt haben und
die die Grünen im Jahr vorher auch schon
führen mussten wir haben eine Opposition
die CDU Herr März Herr Söder die sich im
Prinzip die ganze Zeit mit
Untergangsszenarien die sich in
Untergangsszenarien ergießen die eine
prachialretorik einführen die
offenestanden Frau Kade wenig
lösungsorientierte Alternativen bieten
können wir haben letztes Jahr haben sie
die Debatte geführt ah wir würden
Blackouts haben das Gas würde nicht
reichen der Süden würde würde würde
die Speicher sein nicht
gefüllt der Süden würde quasi kein sich
die die Energieversorgung könnte nicht
sichergestellt werden im Osten haben wir
die Debatte gehabt erinnern Sie sich um
die Raffinerie in Schwed die gasbum
gehörte und die mit russischem Öl
versorgt wurde da hat Herr Wutke gesagt
das Ding wird bite gehen die mer Leute
werden arbeitslos werden an den
Tankstellen wird es kein Benzin mehr
geben und die Benzinpreise werden nach
oben schießen das war die Debatte im
letzten Jahr und offengestanden nichts
davon ist eingetreten
in diesem Jahr nun erleben wir die eine
ähnliche Debatte ums heizungsgesetz und
ja die Grünen haben schlecht
kommuniziert und sie war konnten nicht
darauf reagieren dass sehr frühzeitig
ein Gesetzesentwurf geliegt wurde der in
dieser Form natürlich nicht für die
Öffentlichkeit gedacht war einfach weil
die Fördermaßnahmen noch nicht noch
nicht klar gewesen sind und sie haben
einen Koalitionspartner mit der FDP der
auf teufelkom raus
dieses Gesetz schlecht machen will und
wenn sie in ein wisen sie die breite
Öffentlichkeit interessiert sich doch
nicht für Gesetz
gebungsdebatten wenn ein Gesetz nein ich
glaube nicht ich glaube nichtin ich
glaube nicht ich glaube nicht genauso
wenig wie wir 80 Millionen
Fußballtrainer sind sind nein ne ich
will die anderen auch zum Thema
ranlassen also insofern machen Sie Ihren
Punkt dann Herr me Punkt verloren Herr
Müller machen sie
vielleichter hören und dann können wir
ne das immer so lustig wir haben das
schlecht kommuniziert heißt im Grunde
war ja alles Bombe wir haben nur
schlecht drüber geredet nee das Heß
le verehen die Grüne Partei ist eine
Partei die wahrscheinlich mehr als alle
anderen Parteien einen harten
ideologischen Kern hat oder nennen wir
es freundlicher
Überzeugungstäter Leute wie habbeck
habbeck sind ja sind ja sehr pragmatisch
und habbecks großes Ziel das ist ja
haben sie auch im Eingang ja gesagt ist
jetzt ein bisschen in die Ferne gerückt
ist ja die Eroberung des Kanzleramtes
das ist hat auch noch nicht ganz
aufgegeben und dazu muss ich natürlich
sag ein bisschen geschmeidiger sein und
mehr Leute mit mitnehmen als die harten
Ideologen und was ihm jetzt passiert ist
in dem Fall und das gilt bisschen für
die Klimapolitik
insgesamt ähm dass er nicht aufgepasst
hat bei der Besetzung in seinem
Ministerium wer eben die entscheidenden
Position als staatssekretärer besetzt
und da hat er jetzt einen Mann gehabt
der kommt nämlich genau aus dieser
anderen Partei Teil der Grünen diesen
super ideologischen teil und die haben
ja über die Jahre und Jahrzehnte Papiere
geschrieben wie man Deutschland sagen in
ihrem Sinn verändern kann und
das lustige war hab hat auch mal gefragt
hast du mit allen geredet zum
heizungsgesetz und der dieser
Staatssekretär der berümte Herr greichen
hat immer gesagt ja habe ich mit allen
er hat nur nicht gerade zugesagt dass
die alle die Hände überm Kopf
zusammengeschlagen haben und gesag haben
das funktioniert auf keinen Fall
also ein Auftritt äh Herr Herr greichen
der Staatssekretär tritt vor die
Immobilienwirtschaft großer Kongress
alles Experten und die sagen zu ihm
sagen sie wie soll das denn überhaupt
funktionieren mit dem heizungsgesetz uns
fehlen doch jetzt schon die Monteure da
brauchen wir 60.000 mehr und dann sagt
er einfach so ja da müssen halt ein paar
Leute weniger Fliesen verlegen und mehr
Heizung installieren das zeig
arrogan ich glaube wir sind uns ja hier
in der Runde schon einig das
heizungsgesetz ist nicht glücklich
gelaufen will ich ja dazu kommen das ist
nicht glücklich gelaufen es ist
handwerklich schlecht gemacht gewesen
und es war wahrscheinlich auch schlecht
kommuniziert gleichzeitig war die
Gesellschaft nicht drauf vorbereitet
würde ich alles unterschreiben was aber
auch stimmt ist und wir müssen gar nicht
über den Klimawandel reden also die
Realität oder nicht was auch stimmt ist
wir sind gesetzlich verpflichtet bis
2050 oder früher CO2 neutral zu werden
wir sind gesetzlich verpflichtet in
Europa in Deutschland und weil wir heute
Bayern hatten Bayern will noch früher
CO2 neutral werden wir wissen das kann
man nur erreichen wenn der gebäudestand
Bestand wenn dort weniger CO2
ausgestoßen wird und insofern finde ich
es zunächst richtig dass die Grünen im
übrigen als einzige Partei in dieser
telkoalition zumindest versuchen ein
Gesetz auf dem Weg zu bringen das uns in
Richtung dieses Ziels ein Stück weit
näher bringen könnte und ein Satz dazu
noch was mich jetzt am meisten stört an
dieser ganzen Geschichte dass es so
gelaufen ist wie es gelaufen ist das
haben die Kollegen kollegenin völlig
richtig beschrieben was mich am meisten
bestört ist dass in dieser Koalition in
dieser ampelregierung wird in den
nächsten zwei Jahren nach diesen
Nahtoderlebnis für Robert habbeck und
die Grünen mit dem heizungsgesetz kein
Mensch mehr ein klimagesetz in die Hand
nehmen kein Klimaschutz mehr für die
nächsten zwei Jahre außer ein bisschen
Beschleunigung für Windräder und so
weiter Herr Müller danke sie sind noch
mal dran ich bedanke mich bei allen die
die uns im Netz verfolgen für die vielen
Rückmeldungen bei pressclub und
Tagesschau in unseren Kanälen das
Interessante ist ja dass die Grünen für
diese Politik nicht nur ihre
Zustimmungswerte nicht halten können
sondern sie verloren haben ich lese mal
vor was ein User auf X schreibt warum
setzen die Grünen immer noch einen drauf
warum schaffen sie immer neue Probleme
und bleiben nicht mal bei dem was
eigentlich nötig ist um das erste
Problem zu lösen also daraus lese ich so
ein ein überforder wir suchen ja die
Gründe warum eine Politik so stark an
Zustimmung verliert die wie sie sagen
offenbar ja einen guten Kern und eine
richtige Idee im in mich erinnert und
möglicherweise wissen das die ein oder
anderen der älteren Zuschauer noch wenn
ich das kurz sagen darf mich erinnert
die Situation mit dem heizungsgesetz an
die erste rotgrüne Regierung Gerhard
Schröder da kamen die Grünen auch stolz
geschwellt nach Jahrzehnten in der
Opposition in die Regierung hatten ihre
Projekte und wollten die schnell
durchsetzen natürlich auch berauscht von
der Tatsache dass man nun an der Macht
war Stichwort Reform des Staatsbürgers
rechts doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft sehr
sehr ähnlich die Gesellschaft war nicht
bereit trotzdem wurde das Gesetz durch
den Bundestag gepeitscht was passierte
Roland Koch machte einen Wahlkampf in
Hessen mit einer Unterschriftenaktion
dagegen er hat die Wahl gegen Hans
Eichel gewonnen er hat mit Hessen die
Bundesratsmehrheit für rotgrün gekippt
das Gesetz wurde wie das heizungsgesetz
jetzt in komplett abgespeckter Reform
irgendwie noch mal dann eingebracht das
heißt die Grünen haben es beim
heizungsgesetz versäumt dass es
unstreitig die gesellschaftliche wie
soll ich sagen die gesellschaftliche
Umgebung so zu beackern dass man bereit
gewesen wäre sich darauf einzulassen das
ist richtig und das war ein schwerer
fehlerade ich glaube bei den Grünen
passiert jetzt gerade das wovon sie
jetzt eben Sprachen dass man irgendwie
versucht zu retten was noch zu retten
ist um tatsächlich nicht die nächsten
zwei Jahre gar nicht mehr dieses Thema
anfassen zu können wir haben jetzt
gerade vor ein paar Tagen habeg erlebt
wie er tatsächlich zugegeben hat
dass diese wärmepumpenpläne oder
heizungsgesetzpläne eben bei großen
Häusern die hohen Sanierungsbedarf haben
bis zu 200 000 € pro Haus dann an
Sanierungskosten mit sich gebracht
hätten also sprich das wird jetzt auch
mal ausgesprochen es wird jetzt auch mal
in in in in klaren Zahlen gesagt
was da eigentlich auf die Leute zukommt
das ist glaube ich die Vorbereitung
dessen dass man eben sagt wir nennen das
jetzt alles beim Namen die Leute müssen
die klaren Zahlen vor Augen haben damit
sie bei eventuellen doch noch
klimaschritten die die Ampel noch gehen
will oder die Grünen zumindest dann
einigermaßen mitziehen ja ich fasse mal
zusammen also so Asyl Klimaschutz
Anliegen die in der Schärfe zumindest
von einer Minderheit vertreten werden
aber wo sie sagen handwerklich schlecht
umgesetzt oder kommunikativ schlecht
schlecht vorgetragen es gibt etwas
Drittes was Umfragen immer wieder
deutlich machen das ist das Gefühl
vieler Menschen mittlerweile einer
Mehrheit ja bevormundet zu sein also in
einem aktuellen Deutschlandtrend diese
Woche bestätigen zwei Drittel der
Menschen in Deutschland die Vermutung ja
man werde ausgegrenzt wenn man zu
bestimmten Dingen S meine Meinung offen
sage das ist so ein ja ein ein
Meinungsklima und das Gefühl mir wird
vorgeschrieben was ich essen soll wie
ich sprechen soll was ich tun soll auch
das ist etwas was gegen die Grünen
schlägt zurecht es ist Teil es ist das
Ergebnis dieser monatelang Kampagnen
gegen die Grünen ich weiß nicht wenn sie
mit grünen sprechen
es sind die Konservativen die über
gender die ganze Zeit reden es ist ein
Herr Söder der die ganze Zeit üers
Schnitzelessen referiert und das ist ihm
verbieten wordden wäre also grüne
sprechen gar nicht über solche Themen
ähm also ähm das ist also auch da machen
die schwarzen die professionellere
taktische Politik den besseren Wahlkampf
da ja also wenn Sie das wen ja also
natürlich das das sind relativ einfache
Kampagnen das sind relativ ähm das das
das ist für eine komplexe Situation in
der und das habe ich jetzt schon
mehrmals gesagt äh in der diese
Regierung doch relativ viel versucht
umzusetzen und her ich würde
kommen wre auch aufgab
bundeskanz der sich auch im wahlkf als
klimakanzler plakatiert hat und der das
der das überhaupt nicht überhaupt nicht
tut aber natürlich die Kampagnen der
konservativen und dies konservative
Spektrum von CDU bis AFD bis Freie
Wähler und drüber das sind einfache
Antworten für sehr komplexe Probleme und
nein Herr oder es geht nicht um ändern
und es geht nicht ums Fleisch verbieten
sondern es geht darum dass dass wir
diese Gesellschaft das hat der Müller
auch schon gesagt zur Klimaneutralität
umbauen müssen und ja da müssen wir uns
verändern da müssen wir uns verändern
und dazu sind die Deutschen zu großen
Teilen abstrakt bereit aber wenn es wenn
es konkret darum geht das Leben zu
verändern und
dann dann stößt es auf Widerstände aber
aber es klingt eigentlich wie der Ball
vor dem Tor den man nicht reinschießt ne
die Mehrheit ist dazu bereit und dann
kommen die Widerstände ich w ich würde
es auch nicht so einfach sehen dass man
sagt ja die Konservativen reden da jetzt
fahren Kampagnen und dann ist das
Meinungsbild jetzt plötzlich so ich
meine die Menschen haben doch meinen ja
nicht plötzlich irgendwas was nur weil
Friedrich märz das so sagt oder weil
Markus wöder das so sagt sondern die
haben wie wir ja auch wir hören uns
Politiker an und bilden sich dann ihre
eigene Meinung und genau wie sie sagen
also Friedrich Merz ist ja nun wirklich
auch höchst umstritten Z Recht zu
Unrecht in dem einen oder dem anderen
Fall also da würde ich tatsächlich den
Leuten schon zuelegen dass sie ihren
ihre eigene Erfahrung machen oder ihre
eigene Sichtweise entwickeln jenseits
dessen was Markus Söder im bierzell sagt
na gut also bei den Grünen ist natürlich
äh immer dabei wenn der grüne den Raum
betritt betritt die Aufklärung der Raum
so treten ja grünne auch auf also das
heißt es ist nicht nur einfach ein
Vorschlag sondern der Vorschlag ist
immer irgendwie unterfüttert äh entweder
retten wir gerade das Klima oder wir
retten den Demokratie oder wir kämpfen
gegen Rechts also ist immer ein höherer
sozusagen moralischer Grund so und äh
und es führt natürlich auch dazu dass
man Leute die andere Meinung sind mehr
oder weniger deutlich macht dass man sie
für ein bisschen minder bemittelt hält
und zurück fallallen also wen nicht eben
voll gendert na ja das lernst du auch
noch so
geht also ich bin im Dauerkontakt mit
Grün also meine Erfahrung so und das
Recht sich jetzt wenn man n nicht den
Leuten die ganze Zeit klar deutlich
macht dass man sie ja ein bisschen eben
für minderbemittelt hält also in Berlin
war das ja so war ja ausgesprochen die
Berliner hat eine klimawahl ähm also
alle Menschen guten Herzens dafür die
Grünen haben getrommelt wie verrückt
luisa nauberer hat sich aufs brandburger
Tor gestellt so dann haben sie nicht mal
das mindestquorum erreicht großes
Entsetzen in der grünen Bewegung
Erklärung die Randbezirke sein Schuld ja
da wo die Leute noch an schlittblume
Muttertag und das autoglauben also ein
bisschen die Zusagen der deutsche
bibelbeltt und diese Art von Verachtung
natürlich auch diesem normalen Leben
gegenüber der schlägt sich jetzt auch in
diesen Umfragen nieder herr Möller ja
ähm ich sehe es ein bisschen anders ich
habe es auch anders erlebt weil
sozusagen die Verachtung um das Wort
aufzugreifen von Jan fleischauer die
Verachtung die ich im bayerischen
Landtagswahlkampf sehe die richtet sich
eher von Seiten der Freien Wähler und
der CSU gegen die Grünen als umgedrehte
ähm ich glaube das sozusagen hinter
diesem Kalkül Söders die Grünen
auszugrenzen da gibt's ein kurzfristiges
Ziel und ein langfristiges das
kurzfristige haben wir besprochen er
will halt
klar machen mit den regiert er nicht und
dadurch ein möglich stabiles Ergebnis
für die CSU zu bekommen das langfristige
ist aber doch interessanter wenn sie so
ein Bierzelt gehen chem özemir nicht das
Bierzelt wo der Aufstand gegen ihen war
sondern ganz normales freisingen paar
tausend Leute viel Polizei daher keine
Störung dann sehen sie da Landwirte
junge Leute die irgendwie Unternehmen
gründen was ich sagen will die
diskutieren dann über
Landwirtschaftspolitik da sind auch
Gegner der Grünen Position eingeladen
das fast schon bisschen langweilig für
ein Abend bis öte mir kommt was ich
damit sagen will dass die könnten
genauso bei der CSU sitzen die Grünen
haben sich in Bayern und das ist die
Gefahr für die CSU die haben sich weit
in das bürgerliche Lager reingefressen
Bilderbuch Bayern Landkreis Miesbach
Tegernsee Friedrich Merz Urlaub da sogar
glaube ich
17,5%. das ist die Gefahr im grüner
Landrat eine Zeit lang das ist die
Gefahr vor der die Konservativen in
Bayern zumindest Angst haben und
insofern das bringe ich nicht ganz
überein mit
mit mit der Verbotsdebatte mit der
genderdebatte das mag schon kurzfristig
so sein aber langfristig kriegt die CSU
im bürgerlichen Lager früher 50 + X weil
es allein hatte jetzt haben wir
bürgerliche Wähler die zuur AFD manchmal
gehen wir haben eine klar bürgerliche
Partei mit den Freien Wählern und wir
haben noch so ein bisschen die Grünen
die auch bürgerliches Klientel abgreifen
dann bleiben 35% für die CSU und das ist
auf Dauer zu wenig es ist ja auch
koalitionstrategisch ich finde das ja
sehr lustig und ganz genau ich finde das
sehr lustig und auch ganz ganz putzig
wie Herr fleischauer das beschreibt
wir haben doch aber die Situation ist
doch aber völlig anders schauen sie
sozusagen kein großes
Wirtschaftsunternehmen äh spert sich g
dagegen klimaneutral zu werden die
deutsche Automobilindustrie will
klimaneutral werden das sind nicht
irgendwelche spinnerten Ideen
irgendwelcher irgendwelche
irgendwelcheer irgendwelcheer Leute
denen das Gendern wahnsinnig wichtig ist
sondern es ist eine riesen
Herausforderung eben auch
wirtschaftspolitisch und deseswegen Herr
Müller hat das an den Umfragen
festgemacht ich würde es inhaltlich
festmachen ja die Wirtschaft ist im
Moment in einer keiner guten Phase aber
das ist auch maßgeblich das Ergebnis von
16 Jahren Merkel Regierung und ich kann
nicht erkennen dass die CDU irgendeine
wirtschaftspolitische Idee hätte wie sie
diese ökologische
Transformation Herr linemann kommt und
hat irgendwie die ganz schöne Idee dass
Rentner steuerfrei Arbeiten sollen das
finde ich irgendwie das auch das finde
ich richtig aber diese ökologische
Transformation und ja Herr greichen mag
in ihren Augen ein radikaler gewesen
sein aber die Grünen sind die einzigen
die Konzepte überhaupt in der in der
Schublade für diesen für diesen sehr
anstrengenden Prozess hab zum Schluss
greif ich das Stichwort
koalitionsstrategie auf unsere
demokratie lebt von harter
Auseinandersetzung nicht da wird mit
floret und manchmal auch mit dem
verbalen Schwert gekämpft im Moment
gerade etwas härter das ist der eine
Teil aber der andere Teil ist dass man
ja in Parlamenten Mehrheiten bilden muss
da die SPD vom Zwischenhoch bei der
Bundestagswahl abgesehen nicht mehr als
wirklich große Partei gelten kann war
die Vermutung viele Jahre dass man in
vielen Bundesländern schwarz und grün
braucht um überhaupt
regierungsmehrheiten Ben zu können in
Sachsen und Brandenburg passiert das in
der Kenia Koalition in vier
Bundesländern im Westen ist es
schwarzgrün die Hälfte der grünchwarz
gibt auch oder grünchwarz in
BadenWürttemberg die Hälfte der
deutschen Bevölkerung hat eine
Landesregierung wo schwarz und grün
irgendwie miteinander arbeiten ist das
jetzt zu Ende ist das sozusagen eine
eine Zeitenwende was koalitionstaktik
angeht die wir gerade nee also das finde
ich auch so das nur halbkluge daran also
ich die die Strategie hast die Taktik
haben sie ja beschrieben aber
also sowohl märz als auch Söder wollen
noch irgendwann mal ins
Kanzleramt und das ist extrem unklug
sich jetzt auf dem Weg dahin sozusagen
schon mal eine Koalitionsoption zu
verbauen weil wenn man diese ganzen
Clips irgendwann dann wieder rausholt
2025 dann s sehen die alle beide
ziemlich alt aus von daher ist das schon
nur so halbklug ich verbuche das aber
auch unter einem nicht ganz glücklichen
auch finde ich wenig bürgerlich
bürgerlichen Ton vorgetragenen Versuch
eine Unterscheidbarkeit unter den
Parteien jenseits der AFD sichtbar zu
machen weil ja auch viele Menschen den
Eindruck haben ach das ist doch
irgendwie alles eine Soße nur die AFD
ist eine die äh an ganz andere Position
als alle anderen vertritt und deswegen
sind das für mich die wahren
oppositionsleute also deswegen ist es
finde ich von V von der Anlage her schon
einen Versuch wert zu sagen wir wir
wollen schon klar machen wo wir uns alle
unterscheiden ob man diesen Ton dann
wähen muss das wäre auch nicht meiner
und den finde ich auch nicht bürgerlich
Herr Müller na ja
wir ein Schnipsel den sie nicht gezeigt
haben hätten sie aber zeigen können wir
hatten Friedrich Merz bei der Augsburger
allgemein bei einer großen Veranstaltung
am Freitag vor einer Woche und da haben
wir ihn genau das gefragt sag mal du
sagst da oder sie sagen da am gillamosos
mit den Grünen geht das gar nicht wie
wollen Sie denn regieren und dann hat er
sehr klar gesagt das gilt für Bayern ja
also er hat schon sehr also das hat er
auch erkannt was Frau Kade gerade
durchgespielt hat also wenn man
ernsthaft ob der nun Friedrich Merz ist
bei anderen poten Kanzlerkandidaten
steht ja schwarzgrün noch viel mehr
vorne auf der Rampe wenn man ernsthaft
regieren will im Bund dann braucht man
die Option mit dem grünen ob die dann
kommt oder in welcher Form insofern
Friedrich merärz am Gillamoos ist ein
anderer Friedrich Merz als der dem wir
in Augsburg gehört haben ja K also für
MZ kann ich weiß ich nicht aber für
meinen Ministerpräsident kann ich sagen
also wenn es jetzt sein muss ab
Oktober mit den Grünen dann macht er das
auch mit dem grünen das ist das tolle an
Markus Söder dann war das jetzt auch
richtig in dem Moment wo er so geredet
hat aber jetzt haben wir eine neue Lage
und auf die müssen wir ansprechen
reagieren da kann ich aus Berliner
Erfahrung nur sagen
Herr Wegner hat einen massiven
antigrünen Wahlkampf geführt ich glaube
er hätte gerne mit ihnen koohaliert es
ist einfach nicht zustande gekommen weil
sich so weil man sich derart polarisiert
hatte zwischen beiden zwischen auch den
Landesverbänden also Koalitionen wollen
vorbereitet sein auch das finde ich ein
bisschen leppisch zu sagen ja okay dann
machen wir den bal Koalitionen wollen
vorbereitet sein und was wir ganz stark
an der Ampel sehen ist dass sie nicht
vorbereitet worden ist ich würde zur
momentanen Situation sagen es ist ein
bisschen ein Midterm Phänomen wir gehen
auf zwei sehr wichtige Landtagswahlen zu
die Nerven liegen überall blank ein
Prinzip können im Moment alle nur
verlieren im Moment denke ich ist die
Stimmung so dass niemand eine Koalition
im Bund mit den Grünen machen würde also
auch die Sozialdemokraten würden sich
sehr schnell wieder zurück in eine große
Koalition flüchten oder sogar man würde
eine deutschlandkoalition bauen aber
ehrlich gesagt das kann sich in zwei
Jahren alles wieder geändert ich halt
den Satz gerne fest eine Koalition will
vorbereitet sein haben Sie gesagt ähm
und insofern ist vielleicht die
Kandidatenfrage in der Union auch eine
die am Ende daran hängt mit wem man kann
möchte soll äh ansonsten danke für die
Analyse es hat viel mit Stimmung und
Taktik zu tun habe ich verstanden aber
auch viel mit regierungshandwerk äh dass
sie an einigen Punkten als stark
verbesserungsfähig beschrieben haben
danke dass Sie dabei sind pressclub
nachgefragt jetzt im Netz bei Phönix und
im Radio hier in der ARD ansonsten gute
Informationen im europamagazin unter
anderem über die bald auch in Polen
stattfindenden Balen bis hierhin danke
tschüss und lassen Sie es gut
[Musik]
gehen und willkommen zurück Presseclub
nachgefragt im Fernsehen bei phöniix im
Radio bei WDR5 und auf vielen Kanälen im
Netz und in dienstlaken mit uwen Neuhaus
willkommen in der Sendung Herr Neuhaus
schönen guten Tag in die Runde ich hätte
eine grundsätzliche Frage ist nicht so
dass bei vielen Argumentationen der
Grünen immer so im Hintergrund
Deutungshoheit Hoheitsanspruch zu
erkennen ist und ich finde in der
Demokratie haben deutungshoheiten nichts
verloren in der Demokratie müssen
mehrere Deutungen nebeneinander ihre
Berechtigung haben dann kann man von
einer deutungsmehrheit von mir sprechen
aber nicht von einer deutungsroheit weil
die schließt grundsätzlich dann andere
Deutung aus und markiert sie als falsch
mhm das heißt sie wünschen sich eine
Haltung die sagt das sind meine
Argumente aber ich lasse auch andere
gelten das ist so der Kern ihrer
Beobachtung absolut das ist Demokratie
ja von wem hätten sie gerne Kommentar
dazu vielleicht von dem
fleischchauer gut dass diese Art von
Bescheidenheit die sie da sich wünschen
die fällt den Grünen also wah wahnsinnig
schwer weil sie ja auch in die Politik
gegangen sind natürlich das Land auf den
richtigen Weg zu schupsen und wenn man
das sagen dass dass der der der Ursprung
ist gewissermaßen ja deswegen gibt's ja
auch diese starke Verbindung mit der mit
der evangelischen Kirche also sagen für
höhere Güter zu streiten ja dann trat
man Biss ein anderes Auftreten ne Herr
Neuhaus danke für den Auftakt wir gehen
mal weiter den rein aufwärts nach
koplenz zu Wolfgang natusius Herr
natusius willkommen in der Sendung ja
guten Tag meine Frage an die rund wäre
ob dieser diese hasserfüllte Form
sozusagen das Feindbildes grüne was
jetzt eben so hervortritt zu tun hat mit
einem
autoritätsmangel der Grünen und nicht im
Sinne von autoritär sein also dass die
irgendwie als autoritärere Politiker da
auftreten sollten sondern im Sinne der
römischen autoritas des Ansehens weil
einerseits die Grünen ja fachlich voll
in der Zeit mit den Klimakatastrophen
und den flüchtlingskatastrophen die ja
zum Teil mit der Klimakatastrophe
verbunden
sind aber kein keine wissen oder kein
fachlich überzeugendes Konzept bieten
inem sie jetzt diesen grünlackierten
Kapitalismus weitermachen wollen ja und
damit in Opposition etwa zu einem
realistischen Szenario wie es ri Hermann
entworfen hat kommen und zum anderen
weil sie nicht als politikerpönlichkeit
mit dieser aoritas Auftreten mit der sie
den Leuten wirklich sagen ja es geht an
eure Heizungen es geht so nicht weiter
und das wird Kosten und das eben
deutlicher zu machen und nicht so
zurückzustehen und zu versuchen
irgendwie grünlackierten Konsum
weiterzuführen und man muss sich nur
erinnern die bei Markus Lanz wie
sauertöpfisch die Grünen Ministerin auf
dem Sofa neben Frau Hermann saß vor
einem Jahr und den Fakten nichts zu
entgegnen hatte außer ja ich bin da
nicht so pessimistisch also so sehe ich
das nicht her NAT dan dies
autoritätfrage danke Frau Hensel möchte
erwidern oder kommentieren na ich finde
das sehr interessant was sie erzählen
weil es im Prinzip das Gegenteil von dem
beschreibt was der Vorredner gesagt hat
sie beschreiben jetzt die Grünen als zu
wenig ehrlich
der Vorredner hatte beklagte sich über
das sozusagen dass die Deutungshoheit zu
absolut sei
ähm m
also nach meiner Beobachtung ist es ja
gerade so dass Herr Habig das durchaus
versucht und wir haben kurz über auch
Frau bererburg gesprochen und ihre ihren
Kurs in der in der in der
Migrationsdebatte also ich finde schon
und weil Frau Kard das ansprach das ist
eine Mang dass es einen Führungsproblem
gibt ich finde ja gerade das
interessante so dass dass die Wahl
zwischen Herrn habbeck und Frau berbur
eigentlich auch ein bisschen die Wahl
zwischen zwei politikstilen ist frerb
ist jemand die gerne mit mit einer letzt
mit einer letzten Wahrheit Auftritt
während Herr habik so nehme ich ihn war
ein Politiker ist der sehr gerne viel
für mein verhält für mein Verständnis
viel zu oft Fehler einräumt von viel zu
vielen Zweifeln spricht und von dem ich
mir wünschen würde er würde öfter auch
mal gerade aus argumentieren insofern
kann ich Ihnen teilen Recht geben ja
danke für die Beobachtung jetzt was die
beiden Personen angeht danke schön Frau
Hensel und danke nach Koblenz und
springen wir zurück nach Köln wir
bleiben erstmal am rein heute rundolf
Siebecke willkommen in der Sendung ja
schönen guten Tag aus dem sonnigen Köln
ja ich bin beim gleichen Punkt aber geh
ein Biss weiter zurück und bisschen
tiefer wir haben diese Diskurskultur
geerbt zum Glück Erben dürfen aus dem
alten Griechenland die antiken Denker
dort haben diese Diskurs in seinen
Techniken auch entwickelt das wurde dann
fortgeführt die schulastik ist
vielleicht noch einigen Begriff der
Katholizismus hat das alles sehr
vorangebracht die Klöster haben das sehr
vorangebracht ich behaupte sogar wir
sind ja Unterschied zur Orthodoxie z.B
dass dort diese Diskurskultur nicht gibt
ähm dass unser ganze unsere ganze
Wohlfahrt unsere staatus darauf bes
beruht weil wir immer alles drehen und
wenden und die gemeinsam die Argumente
ausarbeiten und dann eben zu der
bestmöglichen der optimalen
Schlussfolgerung kommen das hat früher
in der Politik auch funktioniert mach ja
bi mal als ein Beispiel jemand der dann
also auch korrigiert hat und
eingegriffen hat von außen und seitd dem
eben ja wir so eine mediale
Öffentlichkeit haben geht es nur noch um
Machtpolitik es wird das gemacht was
sich mit Macht
durchsetzen das wird gemacht bis an die
Wand und vorher wird nicht gestoppt und
das ist ja etwas wo ich von den Medien
erwarte insbesondere von den Medien
erwarte dass sie uns da rausführen die
Politik alleine schafft das
offensichtlich
Nichtarbeit mit den Glaubensgrundsätzen
davon müssen wir weg haben noch viele
danke für für ihren Gedanken dazu Herr
Müller Machtpolitik ist eigentlich ein
ganz gutes Stichwort
im Grunde genommen das haben wir jetzt
ja auch diskutiert ist der Klimawandel
egal wie sehr es die Bevölkerung im
Moment mit den ganzen wirtschaftlichen
Schwierigkeiten im Krieg in der Ukraine
warnend ist das große Thema wo wir uns
irgendwie zu verhalten müssen in unserer
Art zu leben und zu wirtschaften und ich
glaube die Grünen haben ins Amt gekommen
Ministerium Expertise machtpolitisch
gedacht wir haben eine Mehrheit wir
legen dieses heizungsgesetz vor und das
läuft jetzt als 15% Partei verheben Sie
sich an an dieser an dieser
menschheitsaufgabe möchte ich sagen und
ich glaube das ist auch ein Teil was wir
hier erleben wenn wir Klimawandel
ernsthaft bekämpfen wollen dann braucht
man zunächst mal das ist schon
angeklogen die ganze Regierung hinter
sich ja das ist ja auch n wo ist der
Kanzler das kann man in der Tat bei der
ganzen Geschichte Fragen und man braucht
vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr
nämlich im große Teil der Gesellschaft
auch diejenigen die nicht die
ampelparteien gewählt haben hinter sich
Stichwort
macht was mir aber auch auffällt ist bei
so einer Aufgabe die möglicherweise das
ja durch durch die Parteien gar nicht
allein gelöst werden kann zumindest
nicht in diesem Zusammenspiel Regierung
Opposition und es klang schon an wo es
eiglich die Opposition wo ist
der Oppositionsführer Friedrich Merz der
sagt pass auf Robert habbeck das ist so
schief gegangen lass jetzt mal die
Erwachsenen ran das ist mein das ist
mein Klimaschutzkonzept abgestimmt mit
der Wirtschaft das sind die nächsten
fünf Punkte das schaffen wir jetzt bis
zur Bundestagswahl noch das ist ja auch
nirgends und insofern habe ich
vielleicht auch im wie gesagt in dieser
ganzen Sendung gewisse Milde gegenüber
dem was die Grünen da wieder vielen Dank
Herr siebecker auch für diesen Anstoß
ich merke wir rühren an sehr
grundsätzlichen Punkt wir kommen fast
ins Philosophische heute Gruß nach Köln
und wir sind sehr rheinlastig wir
bleiben am Rhein jetzt gehen wir nach
Karlsruhe zu Marvin danncke hallo Herr
danncke willkommen sie haben das Wort
hallo guten Tag ich würde gerne den
Blick weiten auf die FDP als
Koalitionspartner und zwar ist mein
Problem gerade ein bisschen mit der
ideologievorwurf an die Grünen dass die
FDP meiner Meinung nach sogar
ideologischer agiert als die Grünen weil
m das sieht man z.B dar dran dass die
FDP
also für die FDP sind Staatsschulden per
se böse auch wenn viele Ökonomen sagen
dass mehr Schulden gerade für
Investitionen nötig sind und für die FDP
sind außerdem Steuererhöhungen für die
Reichsten der Reichen böse auch wenn
viele fordern dass z.B für die Reichen
die Steuern erhöht werden und für die
restliche Bevölkerung dafür die Steuern
dann ges kt werden und die FDP war auch
beim Thema Energiewende sehr stark für
efuels und Wasserstoff auch wenn z.B
unter Ingenieuren längst entschieden ist
das viel in Richtung
Batterietechnologien deutet also für
mich ist es einfach ein bisschen
kritisch die Grünen so einseitig als
ideologisch zu bezeichnen während die
FDP sozusagen ihre Mantras vor sich hält
und diese als unanfechtbar sozusagen
immer in die ganzen
Koalitionsverhandlungen einbringt und
deswegen haben auch z.B v Z Jahren hat
z.B der Ökonom Adam t auch vor dem
Finanzminister Christian Lindner gewarnt
weil dieser einfach als zu schulden also
Schuldenbremsen pyschistisch quasi
dargestellt wurde deswegen das ist
einfach meine Meinung zu dem ganzen
Thema Herr ja danke dass Sie die mit uns
geteilt haben Frau Kade ist bereit zu
erwidern aber ich merke wir haben heute
viele
belesene
seesene Hörer User Zuschauer ja ich kann
ih ein schzung
eigentlich weitgehend zustimmen
tatsächlich hat die FDP ja die erfahr
gegenteilige Erfahrung gemacht die die
Grünen von den Grünen im ersten
regierungsjahr die Grünen sind von ihrer
Programmatik abgewichen wir haben es
gerade besprochen nicht nur ukrainekrieg
auch die gasbesorgungen die habweg
gemacht hat und so weiter wurden dafür
aber belohnt in den Umfragen und wenn
die Liberalen sich mal haben
breitchlagen lassen war dann gleich
immer hat man gesehen Landtagswahlen und
auch in den Umfragen die Liberalen sind
ja viel stärker jetzt
abgeschmiert in der Ampel als die Grünen
also die Grünen haben ja im Prinzip nur
ein%zentpunkt wenn wir jetzt
den Wahltag sind wo sie genau gen
eigentlich im Prinzip haben die sich
kaum verändert die die FDP ist aber auf
einer auf einem gefährlichen in einem
gefährlichen Bereich angekommen 6 7% das
ist schon heikel und nach meiner Analyse
ist das der Grund dafür dass die sehr
vehement auf ihren Themen beharen und
versuchen so noch zu retten was zu
retten ist Christian l ja sogar schon
mal gesagt ihm reicht auch seine seine
kernliberalen wederschaft und hat gar
nicht mehr den Anspruch wie die grünener
immer noch haben irgendwie grö bester
Welle sie eins hatte ja ja danke und
danke nach Karlsruhe und jetzt verlassen
wir das Rheinland und gehen an die Spray
Astrid Peters in Berlin willkommen
allerschönsten guten Morgen ja guten
Morgen ist gut sind als erstes möchte
ich sagen ich als
hauptschul Schlüsse also ich bin 85 habe
nur die Hauptschule abgeschlossen also
ich habe da verstanden das Gebäude
Energiegesetz ja Gesetz
ähm wer es nicht verstanden hat dass es
hat da haben die Medien einen sehr
großen Teil äh gehabt denn das Gesetz
war noch gar nicht fertig und schon
wurde aus allen Ecken und Enden
berichtet wie schlecht es ist und wie
schlimm das ist und die der alle Bürger
die also eine Heizung haben müssen Ihre
Heizung ausreißen äh
und eine Pumpe da anbringen dazu hatte
also Fokus und äh äh äh die Bildzeitung
und die Welt äh ein
ähäh einen sehr großen Anteil äh mein es
richtet sich hier meine Kritik an die
Medien ich bin darauf angewiesen dass
ich die öffentlich rechtlichen Sender
sehen äh ich kann mir also eine Zeitung
nicht dauernd leisten und ich finde die
Medien sind nicht dazu da Kaffeesatz zu
lesen sondern sie sind so wie Frau
Henschel das Beispiels Weise gemacht hat
dazu zu informieren der Herr habbeck
kann ja nur in einem bestimmten äh äh
äh Zeitraum ähäh erklären nämlich dann
wenn er in die Medien kommt und das hat
er sehr wohl gemacht denn er hat von
Anfang angesagt äh die ähäh Menschen
werden ärmer das hat er schon gesagt und
wenn die Medien aber dauernd darüber
reden dass alle so arm werden und dass
all so teuer ist äh dann sind natürlich
die Menschen sehr gerne bereit das zu
glauben danke für Ihre Meinung frau
Peters danke dass Sie dabei sind in der
Sendung das lassen wir so stehen das war
eine klare pointierte Meinung und gehen
nach appelheim zu Martin Bauer hallo
Herr
Bauer hallo vielen Dank dass Sie mich
drannehmen sie sind auf Sendung bitte
schießen sie los ja sch h vielen Dank
dass Sie mich drannehmenm ich war schon
mal vor einem Jahr im Presseclub daran
ging es um den Atomausstieg und der
wurde sehr hysterisch ich glaube von dem
Weltreporter gesagt dass es Blackout
gibt und der Ende des Deutschlands jetzt
zu meiner Frage äh ich finde Herr habbeg
als ein sehr guten Wirtschaftsminister
und äh er hat das Problem dass er Reform
machen will
und diese Reformen sind natürlich sehr
schwer vermittelbar weil sie eine große
größere Veränderung sind und wir sind
mittlerweile eine sehr alte Gesellschaft
und deswegen sind wir sehr anfällig
gegenüber Populisten wie märz und Söder
die das sehr gut ausnüzen um um um gute
Politik zu diskreditieren deswegen meine
Frage sind wir überhaupt noch
reformfähig mittlerweile weil wir gerade
als ältere Bevölkerung gar keine
Änderung mehr haben wollen ich würde ger
diese Frage an die Reporterin von der
Zeit stellen ja gerne Frau Hensel das
ist eine sehr klare Frage sind wir
reformfähig wenn eine alternde
Bevölkerung möglicherweise andere
Interessen hat oder nicht folgen möchte
ja vielen Dank sind überhaupt äh finde
ich außerordentlich kluge Statements und
Fragen schon die ganze Zeit äh ja
natürlich das sehen wir das haben wir
auch schon kurz besprochen ähm als ich
sagte oder als auch sie sagten dass
übergroße Teile der deutschen äh
klimaneutral werden wollen dass
übergroße Teile der deutschen mehr
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen befürworten wollen
aber das es eben immer dann wenn es in
die konkrete Umsetzung geht die
Widerstände zunehmen ähm insofern ähm
weiß ich nicht ob man den deutschen
gleich Reformunfähigkeit attestieren
will aber ich glaube es braucht eben
dann doch größere Anstrengungen eben der
Bundesregierung
mit dieser Gesellschaft in Kontakt zu
treten und mit ihnen zu sprechen und um
nicht die einzige Frau in der Runde
sozusagen nicht sozusagen zu
kommentieren zu lassen noch einen
Einsatz zu der Dame tut aus Berlin
vorher weil sie hat einen richtigen
Punkt und der verbindet sich mit dem
Anrufer von gerade eben ja ich glaube
auch wir Medien und die
öffentlichrechtlichen gehen da mit gutem
Beispiel voran die von Frau mechberger
publiziert jetzt häufig nach Sendungen
sogenannte faktchecks weil man muss eben
auch sagen dass die Populisten sehr
gerne mit mit mit Vereinfachungen und
auch mit mit Falschaussagen mittlerweile
operieren und ich glaube ja auch wir
Medien müssen uns müssen uns fragen wie
wir in wenn politische Diskurse sich so
radikalisieren wie wir sie im Moment
erleben wie wir als Journalisten damit
umgehen und ob wir einfach Zeit ist
abgelaufen danke für das Schlusswort
danke nach applehe
und ihnen ja einen schönen Sonntag
tschüss und bis nächste
[Musik]
Woche